[Music]
How is your determination to
fulfill what has come to you today? We are in our colleges
[Applause]
God willing, we are good.
Praise be to God. Today is a great feeling of happiness.
Praise be to God. [Music] Lord of the worlds. Praise be to God. We are very happy. [Music] [Applause] [Music] I mean, I hope from the government.  The Turkish people want to complete
Ibrahim’s joy and listen to me. I will enter with him. Being a father, the father
always and forever loves to be next to his son,
God and His blessings. Ibrahim. I
was on the normal course. I
mean, what is the age of a sick person who wants to be with him to
accompany the sick person? Murad must be with him. And who do
I want to hand over this child to?
[Music]
[Music]  ]